a republican lawmaker making perhaps the
most explosive allegation yet concerning
the Biden family business and possible
corruption Senator Chuck Grassley
sending a letter to attorney general
Merrick Garland saying that he's
obtained evidence that shows the FBI got
criminal information from more than 40
confidential sources relating to the
activities of James Hunter and Joe Biden
and worse he claims a bureau is covering
it up Republican Ron Johnson elaborating
on that they actually had a scheme to
downplay not only downplay but to
denigrate any derogatory information on
Hunter biding calling it Russian
disinformation the FBI has thwarted uh
you know legitimate leads and has
prevented its Agents from actually
investigating Joe Biden's
corruption all right Jesse this on the
face of it stinks doesn't it yeah stinks
I think they had more FBI informants on
the Biden family than they had on the
Trump campaign and they had a lot on the
Trump campaign and they had these
informants as way back as when he was
vice president so for the last 15 years
the FBI has had 40 informants feeding
them criminal information about Joe
Biden his brother and his son and every
time it got to headquarters it got wiped
out and they said you know what this is
comes from Russia and it never came from
Russia and then you find out that the
stuff we found out that the informant
said that there was a bribe from Ukraine
for 10 mil they invested at that not
Russia disinformation and then they shut
that down too so they've never
investigated the guy because peers they
don't want to investigate the guy this
guy was just a blocker to make sure
Trump couldn't get reelected that's all
they he was so they dragged a corrupt
old man across the finish line and he's
just sitting there getting us into World
War III just because Trump was a guy
that caught them spying on them cold and
then fired their director ran if you
substitute the name Trump for Biden in
this story would the media be doing more
there wouldn't be any commercials there
would be they' be unble to sell pillows
on CNN uh I sense it would be C they
were already interrupting one of the
biggest most uh most impactful wars ever
to talk about Trump's civil uh Civil
Trial but things are moving forward I'm
somewhat hopeful special Council David
Weiss is coming in behind closed door
November 7th Martin Estrada is coming in
in the next couple of days they're going
to get these people if they have an
ounce of Integrity into them to come out
talk about how they were squelch and
it's so important that Senator Grassley
is doing this not somebody that you can
be labeled a fire brand or or a
extremist Dana if they've actually
genuinely suppressed criminal activity
what should happen I mean one one I
guess a Temptation would be a another
special counsel to look into the special
counsel that's looking into the special
councel and it just gets kicked down the
road and by then it'll be like 2027 and
who knows what will happen I this is why
people have been led to believe that
Biden family membership has its
Privileges and it's that you don't get
any scrutiny you know judge I remember a
couple of weeks before the election I
remember the New York Post had that
Sensational story about Hunter Biden's
laptop which got suppressed suppressed
by social media by Tech Giants by
mainstream media I've always felt that
that actually could have swung the
election if they done their jobs on what
turned out to be a true story that could
have SW the election and everything
since then has been protect the bidens
well there's no question and and studies
show that it would have changed the
election that people were asked you know
if you knew this would you have changed
your vote there's no question but you
know think of the idea that there were
40 different informants 40 different
people going to law enforcement and law
enforcement has a cabal in the center
that says anything related to the bidens
we're going to get rid of And yet when
it came to Donald Trump they made
something up and then they went directly
to the press to tell the American people
that these a Putin puppet in a Russian
asset whereas these 40 informant go to
law enforcement maybe they should have
gone to the press in the first place and
we might have heard more about it but
they are as corrupt as the day is long
and there is also they're talking about
getting a Joe Biden's bank records
because it won't be complete until they
do and if you're an FBI informant and
you want to come to the Press Jesse
wat's prime time it's a great place hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else